i crystally had cracked me up when he
was washing his hands there's Instagram
did you see that dude he is so [ __ ]
funny
and then the weightlifting thing he's so
funny your special drops April 19th
our 1414 sign for TF yeah do you know
whose special is [ __ ] fire Tom Segura
I gotta see it I want all the specials
Tom yeah Tom to me
he was harm the pain he's hilarious how
is amazing please play this of Chris
doing this gin sir there's a lot of
discrepancy upon how long as you do
looks good to keep clean for this
coronavirus so what I do is I sing a
full song while I'm washing my hands
this way I know yes [ __ ] all over sure
but whatever my hands are completely
clean so you can pass this along your
friends and family but this is how it
goes little bit of water it's too easy
the weight lifting what No oh my god go
to the good it go to this one watch it
watch this no this one it looks good man
legs are very skinny here we go some to
show you for quarantine work out here
with the [ __ ] witch what my hips are
crying but really that's just a [ __ ]
teardrop over my kneecap Johnny [ __ ]
hips cry you know
never stopping fitness in flipster foot
almost passed out he's such an idiot
with his Tom waited fast he's funniest
person man I agree place person only
lives his brother said Chris from the
age of five only lived to make people
laugh it's all he likes to do that
everything else is born was it you and
him of the funniest people I know man no
one makes me laugh farther than Chris in
you it's just so [ __ ] stupid funny
frustrating so stupid he's so funny
I was like why didn't I think of that I
know you see it I'm like [ __ ] I know
I literally he puts me on notice cuz I'm
like I gotta start there's no been
funnier oh you know him better oh he's
so fuss such an eccentric he's such a
weird he's such a comic I can exchange
gossip I can't wait for this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]